The first laser beam attack and history occurred on August the fourth, 2019.
And I'm being serious. I have not lost it.
Laser beams really do exist and have already been used in.
[Inaudible].
Well, we are talking about the demolition of a combat room in the ceremony.
War.
Rune belongs to the Syrian rebels. And who do you think fired the laser beam?
Which country could be advanced enough to have laser weapons ready to fire?
Many of you will guess the United States or maybe China or Russia. Well,
believe it or not,
the first country to use laser beams in human history was older run. No kidding.
It was Turkey.
It's Turkey.
No, I guess your head has already exploded.
How is it possible that laser beams exist?
And how is it possible that Turkey has them before any other country?
Since when is Turkey a tech leader and how exactly delays or beams work,
don't worry. And this video, we're going to explain everything let's get.
[Inaudible].
The question many of us are asking ourselves right now is who needs Netflix in
the year 2020. If everything we hear in the news is real.
It's almost as if Alex Jones has possessed us all this year.
We have seen the SARS coronavirus two pandemic,
the seizing of Hong Kong by China and even Bruce Willis dressed up as Mon.
Hi.
Things couldn't possibly get any weirder, right? Well,
in case all of this wasn't enough. We're now bringing you laser beams.
We've seen them in hundreds of movies, and now they're a reality.
And many of you will be thinking, but apart from cutting,
what advantage to laser beams have over, let's say ordinary missiles. Well,
lots, basically a laser beam travels at the speed of light,
which means it is practically impossible to Dodge
Clear definition of perfect shot. In fact, thanks to laser beams.
Turkey was able to take down a moving drone with complete precision,
and you'll say, but how do laser beams work? Well,
that is why we're going to have to talk about quantum physics.
And please don't leave.
Jay's not going to be as boring as your physics classes in high school.
For that reason, Javier son, Viola has advised us in the making of this video.
And I'd like to apologize to Javier for how I just pronounced his name.
He is one of the most famous physics YouTubers in Spanish.
Have you want to take a look at his channel?
It's in Spanish and the link is here, but that's not all.
He's also one of the scientists who discovered the Higgs boson. In other words,
we're talking about the real deal in the world of physics.
But before we talk about science,
we need to talk about politics because my visual polar Migos Turkey is kingdom
NATO's.
Boy.
That is if ethnical was the classic school in a 1980s, film,
Turkey would be the class thug. The one who's always looking to pick a fight.
Everyone, for example.
Turkey gets along really badly with Greece,
which is also a natal member and the United States,
which would be the captain of the American football team.
In the school scenario we were talking about does not sell weapons to Turkey.
And since the Turks can't buy guns from the United States,
what do you think they're doing? Well, here is a clue.
[Inaudible].
Turkey's is it bought Russia's S 400 air defense system to use it not to put it
aside.
It seem insignificant, but this news is actually very important.
At the end of the day. Russia is NATO is antagonist and Turkey,
which is a member of NATO is buying weapons from them.
That is something that we asked NATO, secretary general yen, Salton Berg,
when we interviewed him last year.
And of course these new, uh, um, uh,
S 400, uh, air defense systems, uh,
which are Russian will not be integrated into Nate.
Those integrated air missile defense.
There will be a standalone thing outside the natals, uh, elephant system.
But not only that Turkey is one of the countries that spends the most money on
its military. And in fact,
they have the second largest army of all the NATO countries after United States.
At least as far as the number of soldiers is consent. Of course,
when we talk about defense soldiers,
aren't everything technology and weaponry are becoming increasingly more
important. And in that aspect, Turkey has never been a leading player.
Think of it this way. Although, as a country that has 80 million inhabitants,
it only has the same level of GDP as the Netherlands.
And that's why it's so amazing, but they pioneered laser beams.
How is that possible? Why does Turkey have laser beams? How do they work today?
We're going to answer this question, but first let's look at some history.
NATO's bad boy, before.
We go any further, I want you to take a look at this.
This is the Bosphorus straits and belongs to Turkey. However,
this street is the only direct access to the Mediterranean that Russia could
have for centuries. Russia has wanted to control it, and Turkey will let them,
both countries do not know the meaning of the word diplomacy.
And this explains why Russia and Turkey have been sworn enemies for centuries.
Yeah.
What does all this mean then? Well, during the cold war, it meant a lot.
Basically Turkey was the most anti-Soviet country in the world,
and that's why in 1952, they joined NATO.
Ultimately NATO was a military Alliance to defend itself against the Soviet
union.
And Turkey had a very large army and plenty of anticommunist credentials to be
received by needle with open arms.
No problem. Well, as we said before,
Turkey is the bad guy in class and they don't get on with anybody.
Think about it. Turkey has a long and rich Imperial past for centuries.
Turkey was known as the Ottoman empire and dominated a huge territory.
This Imperial past left many dead along the way,
including a genocide against the Armenians clashes with the Kurdish minority and
an ongoing conflict with Greece over the Island of Cyprus. And you'll say,
is this really a problem today? Well, the truth has yet in 1974,
Turkey invaded the Island of Cyprus.
Since then the Island has been divided into two halves on one,
they speak Turkish and on the other.
Do you speak Greek.
And imagine Greece,
which is also a member of NATO does not get along with Turkey.
This all helps explain why. And the 1970s, the United States said to Turkey,
okay, there Turkey. We're going to protect you.
But since we don't trust you at all, because of your inherent bad Boyness,
we're not going to sell you any guns. Goodness knows what you do with them.
And I'd like to apologize to all the Americans for the accent, but anyway,
Turkey is officially an ally of the United States,
but can hardly buy any weapons from them.
And what do you think Turkey's answer was well, Rachel, then,
since you want to sell me your guns,
I guess I'll just go ahead and create my own arms industry and the problem apart
from the fact that I can't do a Turkish accent, well,
Turkey doesn't have any silicone Valley or anything that looks remotely like it.
So what happened for decades?
The most remarkable thing in Turkey had for the Jew Baria missile launchers,
the biggest ones,
Apart from that, no one has ever said, Oh, Turkish, military technology,
give me 10 of them. In fact, in the two thousands,
the anchor government began to shelve all these military programs after all.
Why did they want so many weapons if they were already protected by NATO?
Interestingly, these were the years when Turkey began to grow economically.
It was even discussed whether they could join NATO irate,
but all this changed in 2016. So what happened in 2016? Well.
[Inaudible].
They will pay a heavy price for their treason,
Turkish soldiers surrender on Bosphorus bridge.
After overnight military coup fails ending with 250 dead as
president air to one bows. Revenge.
Exactly. We are talking about the coup against Turkey's president Erdogan,
a coup that many believe was set up by Erewhon himself and event that gave him
the perfect excuse to change the country's constitution and secure even more
power since then.
Everyone's new goal seems to be the restoration of the Ottoman empire to control
North Africa again. So the whole world will be afraid of the Turkish army.
And at the same time, the Turkish army would also be afraid of Erewhon.
And that's why he took measures.
[Inaudible].
And purges army and judiciary after failed.
To give you some idea. After this military purge,
there was only 20 fighter pilots left. That is Turkey has 200 fighter planes,
but only 20 people. You can actually fly them.
And something similar happened in the other divisions of the army,
basically by removing all the factions that might be against him.
Everyone has been left with a skeleton army, and you're probably wondering,
so how is he going to expand the new Ottoman empire without any soldiers? Well,
everyone has tried to buy weapons from the United States.
Turkey seeks us Patriot missiles to deter Russia and Syria.
As you can imagine, America's answer was, let's see here to when kiddo,
what do you want those Patriot missiles for? Huh?
You're not going to use them to kill Kurds again, are you?
I've got my eye on you, you know, far from falling in with air Dwan.
Trump has put new sanctions on Turkey.
Why punishment for mistreatment of the Kurdish minority? I,
my Northy as an ally of the United.
Stinks.
The idea the Kurds have been instrumental in the fight against ISIS.
So Trump is not going to sell weapons to Turkey, to attack his own allies.
As I told you earlier, Turkey is still NATO's bad, boy. Yes, we have his back,
but we're interested in keeping track of him as well. So once again,
NATO is protecting Turkey, but doesn't want Turkey to have its a weaponry,
which explains news.
Spain extends air defense system deployment in Turkey.
This all mean, well,
Spain is an ally of the United States and has Patriot missiles.
NATO has told them to set up a few to protect Turkey's border with a run,
but that's all. And as you can imagine, that doesn't make Erawan very happy.
He wants to have his own weaponry and his own military doctrine. In fact,
Turkey is a player and the Libyan war and they have their own alliances and
their own strategy separate from NATO. That's what they need weaponry for.
So as the United States continues its policy of not selling them. Weapons.
Turkey has reopened as military industrial development programs and those
programs include technology like this.
[Inaudible] laser weapons system to strengthen military. So.
Laser beams have many advantages.
They are a very promising technology to defend against anti aircraft attacks and
to operate them. You need a new military personnel. I mean,
everyone has the perfect excuse to hire new soldiers who are loyal to him.
But the question is, what are laser beams? Why are they used for well.
[Inaudible] laser beams, the new gunpowder.
So we are talking about one of the most important inventions of the century so
much so that there are up to five Nobel laureates who have been awarded for the
development and applications of lasers since 1964.
And the applications are many and varied from barcode readers and metallurgy and
medicine and optics or for aiming at the goalkeeper of the rival team.
And of course, yes.
Also to use in war haze because of its special features that you're going to
freak out and behind it is not an ordinary man,
but possibly the best physicist of all tank Albert Einstein and his development
of quantum mechanics.
But first let's talk about the laser. The laser is late normal,
ordinary light. Yes. Like the sun or the bathroom light and your hypes.
But of course you're not going to use a flashlight to shoot down drones. No,
because that would be just silly. The laser is light. Yes,
but it's a very special light and physical,
which is the language that physicists speak.
We see that is monochromatic coherent. And.
Hold on a minute.
What does all this mean? Monochromatic means of a single frequency,
a single color focused is that it does not despair us and coherent is the way
that the waves marched to the beat.
That is the laser is composed of very neat light particles.
[Inaudible].
Perhaps the best way to understand the difference between a flashlight and the
laser beam is to compare it to an army.
The light of the torch would be like the army of the barbarians and gladiator
everyone's on the room and the laser army.
We would have to imagine perfectly formed soldiers, marching,
an order synchronized running like clockwork to continue with the metaphor.
It would be like the Roman army perfectly organized with everyone marching.
[Inaudible].
This is thanks to the quantum properties of matter. And in particular,
the layered structure of atoms,
something that could only be understood with the advent of quantum mechanics,
Einstein. So, and this new conception of atoms,
this interesting application that could only be realized over the decades after
he had died in the 1960s,
Unique properties,
the laser is able to concentrate a lot of energy and very little space and also
impulses of short duration, which muscly multiplies its power.
We're talking in the order of 10 rays to 23 Watts per centimeter,
Thanks to a revolutionary invention,
applied to the laser for which Mulrooney and Strickland won the Nobel prize in
2018.
With.
A high powered laser like this, you can easily shoot down a drill, deflect,
a missile, or even send a ship to alphas and Torah among other things.
And so we enter a new year. The age of the laser, the Sith had better watch out,
but as you can imagine,
Turkey is not the only country to have laser beam weaponry.
They're the first to have tried them in a real combat scenario.
But the United States has its own weapons where they've digging too deep and
May, 2020, while we were all confined at home.
The U S Navy carried its first laser beam test. The border.
China is also doing its own research in this field.
So now we're going to hand the question over it to you.
Do you think we're looking at a new way of making war?
To what extent will laser beams end up replacing muscles and rifles,
and more importantly, will Turkey end up building his new Ottoman empire,
leave your answers for us in the comments below.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video. Please hit like if you did,
and don't forget to subscribe for brand new content from us every week.
If you had the little alarm button down there,
you'll be able to get updates for when they come home. Also,
don't forget to check out our friends at the reconsidered media podcast.
They provided the vocals in this episode that we're not my dulcet tunes. Also,
this channel is possible because of Patrion and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll see you in the next video.
Can I get my laser goodnight, please, if you.
And more about politics and world affairs and here's some more of my lovely
voice, um,
check out the reconsidered podcast where we don't do the thinking for you find
reconsider@wwwdotreconsideredmedia.com or on Apple or
Google play or your favorite podcast.